you ever seen a ghost I've seen a ghost
I have a picture of the ghost I saw is
this the picture of the ghost I'm going
to show you the ghost okay I'm gonna
look at the picture and you tell me the
tail I got one of those Nest cameras
and it was the first time that I had one
and I a lot of hauntings are sponsored
by nest
[Laughter]
and I was in Denver at The Comedy Works
and I got the alert on my phone we've
seen activity and I was and I I was like
oh that's cool I didn't know it did that
and I said oh I said to my opening act
that would be a cool beginning of a
horror movie you get you're out of town
and you get an alert from your nest and
you turn it on and there's just someone
staring at you in your office as I say
that bling I get another alert as you
say it and that's the picture that it
took
Oh weird
no me gusta